what about human relations you mentioned
finding love
are the flaws in humans any perfection
in humans a component of love like what
role do you think the the flaws play
it's a that's a really profound question
I think
the flaws are there uh
to
the flaws are there to present a a
vulnerability and those flaws are
um
are
um a sign of those vulnerabilities
and I think
love is very very gentle right love
with Bill we often talk about between
the two of us about what drives all
human behavior and for him it's
incentive as you might expect and he
will repeat this sentence to me all
incentive drives all human behavior but
I I would say to me it's love love very
much so
um and
and I think flaws are part of that
because flaws are a sign of that
vulnerability whether physical whether
emotional vulnerability and those
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
they either tear us apart or they bring
us together
um the vulnerability is what is the glue
I think I think that the vulnerability
enables connection the connection is the
glue and that connection enables
accessing A Higher Ground as a community
as opposed to as an individual so if
there is a society of the mind or if
there are higher levels of awareness
that can be accessed in community as
opposed to
again going to the silkworm as opposed
to on the individual level I think that
those occur through the flaws and the
vulnerabilities and without them we we
cannot find connection community and
without Community we can't build what we
have built as a civilization you know
for the past hundreds of thousands of
years so I think not only are they
beautiful but they have a functional
role in in building civilizations
yeah there's a sense in which love
requires vulnerability and maybe love is
the leap into that vulnerability and I
think yes I think
law think about it like physically
I'm thinking about
a brick that's flawed but in a way the
the I think of a flaw as a as an
increased surface area
[Laughter]
that's a good line right a surface area
that like physically underlined
emotionally right it sort of introduces
this whole new dimension to a human or a
brick and because you have more surface
area you can you know use mortar and
build a home and and yeah I think of it
as accessing this additional dimension
of surface area that could be used for
good or bad right to to to connect to
communicate to collaborate
it makes me think of that quote from
this incredible movie I've watched years
ago
Particle Fever I think it was called
documentary about the Large Hadron
Collider an incredible film where they
talk about the things that are least
important for our survival are the
things that make us human
like the the pure romantic act or you
know the notion of and and Victor
Frankel talks about that too
he talks about
feeling the sun on his arms as he's as
he is
um
working the soil in
two degrees Fahrenheit with without
clothes and
the officer
berate him and says what have you done
have you been a businessman before you
came here to the camp
and he says I was a doctor and he said
you you must have made a lot of money as
a doctor and he said I all all my work
I've done for free I've been helping the
poor
um but he keeps his he keeps
his
um humility and he he keeps his
um modesty and he keeps his
preservation of the spirit
um
and he says the things that actually
make him able to or made him able to
outlive the the Terrible
um experience in the Holocaust was the
the really cherishing this moment when
the Sun hits his skin or when he can eat
it
um a grain of rice a single grain of
rice so I think
cherishing is a very important part of
um living a meaningful life being able
to cherish those simple things
like to notice them until to notice them
to pay attention to them in the moment
and I I do this now more than ever
I mean there is some the Bukowski has
this poem I like called Nirvana
where it tells the story of a young man
on a bus going through like North
Carolina or something like this and they
stop off in a cafe and he has this
there's a waitress and just he talks
about that he notices the magic
something Indescribable we just knows
it's the magic of it and he gets back on
the bus with the rest of the passengers
and none of them seem to have noticed
the magic
and
I think if you just allow yourself to
pause it just to feel whatever that is
maybe maybe ultimately it's a kind of
gratitude yes
for
I don't know what it is
it's just that I'm sure it's just
chemicals in the brain but it's just so
incredible to be alive yeah and noticing
that yes and appreciating that and being
one in that with others yes yes
it goes back to
you know to the fireplace right to the
First Technology what was the first
technology it was fire First Technology
to have built community and it emerged
out of a vulnerability of wanting to
stay away from the cold and be warm
together
and and and of course that fire is
associated with not only with comfort
and the ability to
form you know
biorrelevant nutrients in our food and
and and and and provide heat and comfort
but also spirits and
and
um a kind of a way to enter you know to
enter a spiritual moment to enter
a moment that can only be experienced as
as
in a community as a as a form of a
meditative moment
there is a lot to be said about light
light
um is I think an important part of
these moments
of
I think I I think it's a real thing I I
really truly believe that we're born
with an with a
with an aura surface area that is
measurable I think we're we're born into
the world without you know
with uh
with an aura
and
um and how do we channel that is really
is sort of ends I mean and ends up sort
of defining
you know defining the light in our lives
do you think we're all do you think
we're all lonely I think there's
loneliness in US humans oh yes yes
loneliness is part yes I think we we all
have that loneliness whether we're
willing to access that loneliness and
look at it in the eye or completely
[Music]
um
you know completely avoid it or deny it
it's like uh it feels like it's a some
kind of foundation for longing and
longing leads to this uh this
combination of vulnerability and
connection with others yes it feels like
that's a really important part of being
human is being lonely very it's very we
are born into this world alone
again being alone and being lonely are
two different things right and you can
be together but be lonely and you can be
alone but not be lonely at all
we often joke bill and I that
um he he cannot be lonely he cannot deal
with being by himself he always needs
people around him and I strive long
um must have creative Solitude must find
pockets of solitude and loneliness
in order to find creativity and
reconnect with myself
so loneliness is a recipe for
um for community in my opinion and I
think those things complement each other
and they're synergetic absolutely the
yin and yang of of
of of togetherness
and they allow you I think to yeah to
reset and to tune in
to
that ratio we talked about of who you
are and who you want to be